- [Narrator] This Great Big Story was
made possible by Japan Airlines.
(steady piano music)
(indistinct background chatter)
(curtains sliding open)
(speaking foreign language)
Choko's school in Tokyo, Japan,
teaches people how to be mascots,
because the business of
being a mascot is big.
Really big.
Mascots in Japan aren't just for sports.
They're for police departments, towns,
malls, airlines, even prisons.
They're a staple of Japanese culture.
In Osaka alone, at one time there was
one mascot per 6,000 residents.
(jaunty instrumental music)
- One, two, jump.
- [Narrator] So she teaches them to wave,
to dance, to pose,
and her class is diverse.
He's a former chef.
She's a housewife.
This guy, he is a professional mascot.
Their ultimate goal, it's to perform.
But of course, there are rules.
Number one: no talking.
Number two: don't show any skin.
Number three: don't be rude.
These rules are here for one reason:
a mascot is more than just a costume.
(speaking foreign language)
(laughs)
Being a mascot is about becoming
something greater than yourself.
You can escape into the character.
In fact, that's what
you're supposed to do.
Choko's been doing this for over 30 years,
and her students, well, they seem
like they're on the right track.
Keep on practicing, guys.
(singing in foreign language)
(clapping)
(musical note plays)